So when you're coming back from
all these summits and all these,
this time at altitude,
what has actually happened to your body
that causes you to be really depleted
for six months? Like what? What's,
what's happening other than the fact that
you were at high altitude, low oxygen,
like what's taking place?
So one of the things that happened to
high altitude that you don't really think
about too much,
which is your body's not getting,
so the air actually has just as much
oxygen in it as it does at sea level.
But the air is less dense.
So that means as you breathe in the air,
you're literally getting less oxygen
into your blood. It's less dense,
it's less nitrogen, the pressure
changes, right? So at the high altitude,
it's actually the pressure that's
changing. It's not less oxygen,
there's just as much oxygen,
but in a less dense form.
So in the same volume of breath,
you're getting less actual
o two into your blood.
And what are you at a higher altitude, I
guess? Uh, carbon dioxide. Is that right?
Yeah. I'm not a doctor. Like I said, all
I know is you're getting less oxygen. Um,
you're getting less oxygen,
your body.
So what ends up happening is your
muscles of course need oxygen to perform.
So normally if I'm in a, you know, when
I'm in my most elite physical shape,
you know,
I resting heart rate during a professional
triathlon career of like 35 getting
out of bed,
you know,
38 low enough that if you weren't a
professional athlete and you went to a
doctor with a heart rate of
35, they'd be like, oh my God,
like you're going to die.
There's something wrong with
you. But like that's also,
you know, a key marker of elite
performance. You know, that of course. Um,
but uh,
what happens is your body can't PR,
your body's getting so little auction,
even as your blood is acclimatizing,
you're sleeping with a resting heart
rate at altitude on Everest at like 9,000
beats per minute. So, you know,
that's pretty elevated heart rate,
24 hours a day. And for, in my
case, for 139 days straight.
So essentially you're just
career heart. It's just like
cook, Cook, Cook, Cook, Cook,
Cook, Cook, Cook, Cook, Cook,
Cook up and cook even at rest.
And so what that does to your
body in terms of, you know,
it throws your hormones around it
obviously you lose body weight, body fat,
body composition, changes, all of those
things really shift and happen, uh,
in a pretty intense way.
So coming back,
like actually just getting your heart
rate back down, getting your, you know,
a pair of simple nervous system to just
relax and stress free and all that kind
of stuff.
It takes a while for sure.
So what do you do to help yourself
recover when you come back?
Because there specific kinds of
food that you eat or supplements
sick. Um, you know, I'll
start the few different things
that I find to be the work.
Well, one sleep. I mean,
I think that sleep in our culture in
general is really underrated. I think,
you know, if you go in the
corporate world and everyone's like,
I pulled this all night or I work in 120
hours a week, I this, I that or whatever.
Like,
you know,
I'm telling you a story about pushing
through the night and going 32 hours
straight. There's a time and a
place for big pushes without sleep.
But like we are not built
to do that sustainably, um,
in any way, shape or form.
So in my training, when I'm training
for these things, I prioritize sleep.
I prioritize taking a nap,
the same thing when I'm recovering.
So really making sure I get
that sleep is the most for me,
the most natural way to recover.
And top of that soft tissue work.
I'm a huge believer in massage,
um, as well as chiropractor.
I've been going to a chiropractor since
I was a little kid and to me that makes
a big difference. Just have everything in
alignment, everything kind of, you know,
working well, uh, efficiently in my body.
Um, and then yeah, supplements, you know,
definitely reducing inflammation.
So for me, gut health is huge. Um,
so getting those probiotics, getting
the right stuff in, you know,
it's easy to have,
you know,
that leaky gut or things where you're
not getting nutrition observed,
absorbed properly. And I think we
all in various states, you know,
you deal with that, you know, that
the standard American diet for sure.
What leads to that for a lot of people.
Um,
so getting that nutrition clean and
right. Um, so yeah, sleep, rest, recovery,
nutrition. Um, and then, you
know, I've definitely been, uh,
taken a lot of supplements
through my life.
I err more towards the
whole food supplements these
days, but I find, you know,
things like Tumeric that really reduce
inflammation. Um, and, uh, you know,
magnesium definitely helps a lot.
So there's a few things that I,
that I take daily,
but a really,
I think sleep and in a clean
diet will goes a long way.